I'm here with Rebecca from the glamour
beauty team and we're talking everything
foundation so before we try the
foundation I really want to prime your
skin so I'm using the fix and protect
primer which is an SPF 25 this is a
really great anti stress anti-pollution
primer you can focus on the t-zone and
this is going to really help to extend
the look of your fresher skin foundation
and we're about to try out the Rimmel
freshest skin foundation which for me
kind of it's a bit of a genius product
it does pretty much everything as a
makeup artist the Highwood one it's
really breathable it gives a lightweight
coverage it's almost invisible on the
skin you know if you're looking for that
kind of ultimate no makeup makeup finish
it perfects your skin without looking
like a heavy base brilliant well I'm
using one of Ribble's brand new Royal
blush which have cream blushes your one
of the simplest ways to apply cream
blush is video fingertips and a pop a
little bit on the apple of each cheek
and then just blend it through and I
really like the idea of cream on top of
this lightweight foundation just what's
really natural so are you ready to
finish your fresher skin look yeah I'm
ready now Rebecca I've noticed you're a
bit of a fan of an eyebrow yeah I have
just the product for you I'm using
remote brow this way which is a really
great duo just working with your natural
brow shape let's apply a little bit of
moisture you Sheeran shine lipstick in a
tone that will just naturally enhance
your lips so that's a finishing touch to
your fresher skin makeup look